Thank you.
This is what I was doing.
I was like, even this way.
I was trying to put on this reindeer.
And it's like, oh my god, I thought it'd be so easy.
I was like, okay, I'll do this like 20 minutes before the
street.
It was not easy.
It was not easy, but look, look at me, I'm a reindeer.
Oh my god, okay, then I was trying to figure out like, cause
like you could change the colors.
I was like, how the fuck do you change the colors?
They're like, I was reading the instructions and it was
saying like, oh yeah, don't worry, ask toggles to change the
colors.
And I'm like, how the fuck did they did they didn't list
they didn't list what the toggles were So I was trying to
figure out what the fuck were the keys or this I was like
fuck this is it and it was One two three four it was look I
have buddies look it's brown now and then I have it comes in
red I don't know if I like I don't know it comes in red and
then I have like these little buddies And then there's it
comes in black and it comes in green and that is all the
toggles it I think that's all of them, but I thought it was
so cute.
Yeah, it's RGB odd.
I don't know.
I think green is my favorite So I did the green version or
the white version.
The only thing I don't like is the it's the snowman guys
like what are you doing here?
It's RGB.
Yeah.
Okay, guys.
So that is that is why I was late.
Turkey with your red eyes so bright won't you guys dance
late tonight.
Thank you.
The rich and selfish.
Oh, Jakarta, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Merry Christmas, Eve, reindeer, doki, just wrapped up a
Christmas Eve party.
I'm only going to be ready to relax with some panidoki,
laughter, and cheer the dragons.
Thank you for streaming tonight.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I know, I was like, earlier today, yesterday, I was
like, do I do a night stream, evening stream, or an
afternoon stream?
I was like, fuck it, I'll do both in the spirit of the
holidays.
I'll do both.
them obviously won't be a very long good night dragon stream
i'm gonna cap myself for around an hour or so an hour and a
half max because tomorrow is where we're doing the big
stream i don't want to tire myself out because i still have
to prep for tomorrow i still have to get all the assets
going on for like what i want to use for it and also like
i'm still prepping for the 900k stuff too So there's a lot
of stuff going.
I'm really, really behind.
I should have prepped it on the 22nd and 23rd instead of
going outside.
But I had to do the Costco ride.
And I had to go to the Christmas market.
So that's not me.
Like Pat Stokey fucked me up.
Heck, I think of a Super Chat.
Thank you.
Merry Christmas, Stokey.
Are you at a dinner or are you shooting dinner this year?
I hope you have a happy 2026.
Think of a Super Chat.
Thank you.
I am never the prey.
Always the predator.
I am rank one in the tier list of prey and predator.
I am the top of the food chain.
Solid snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She is a reindeer.
It was worth it.
Very cute.
Happy Christmas to you and the dragons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Solid.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Yeah, that was worth it.
I told you.
It was worth it.
Look how fucking cute this is.
Wow, oh my god, I'm a reindeer I was wanting to play around
with these with these assets and clothes and stuff now I
can't I was wondering You might be noticing like I'm missing
some parts and I was like wondering how they because like if
I put the I had to cut my I had to cut my wings don't worry
I'll grow them back during the summer guys I had to don't
actually I could grow it back the next day I grow I grow
hair very fast So I had to cut my wings.
You can see that it's gone right now.
That's why it also took me so long.
I had to cut it, see?
You know how when you had to...
You had to trim the feathers off.
So I trimmed my feathers real quick.
Because I had to put on...
It kept popping off of the hoodie.
So I had to trim it off.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, unbirds your dokey.
Look, don't wings.
bread dump boy where is the bread comes from i'm doki the
deer now uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i'm doki deer uh maddie thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you this is the only christmas gift i can afford
and then christmas christmas thank you the super chat maddie
thank you thank you it's okay maddie it's okay focus on
yourself all right i really appreciate the super chat and
you being here i really appreciate it guys um let's see
where was that uh cas thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you hello hello turkey merry christmas very late for
me so i'm actually going to go to bed right now wishing you
all the dragons a very fun stream thank you thank you thank
you i hope you guys had a good christmas eve i know some of
you guys celebrate christmas eve with your family and
friends i hope you guys had a good christmas eve tomorrow is
christmas oh and also christmas for those who are on the
other side of the world um those who are on the other side
of the world had a great christmas those tomorrow and hope
you guys be able to wake up in time tomorrow for your
Christmas parties for those who are in on my side of the
world oh my god Jesus happy birthday Jesus Merry Christmas
dear kid and a happy birthday to you Jesus thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you I'm so glad it's actually
pretty funny that like on his birthday you give me a gift
Wow Jesus is so kind
was that?
Uh, I fell in.
I think of the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Merry Christmas, Doki and Dragoons.
Hope everyone's having a good one.
Thank you.
The Akasupa.
Smug.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know when we needed him the most, he comes back.
Merry Christmas, Doki and Dragoon.
Congrats on 900k again.
Doki, dear.
It's so cute.
I died.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm trying not to like I luckily I ordered a bunch of those
like the Chinese syrup not how are they called the little
syrup things that all the professional voice actors and
singers use to make sure their voice don't don't collapse on
itself so I ordered a bunch of those a couple of days ago so
I'm definitely gonna have some of the have like a like a
spoonful of the the syrup things at the pay pie pay pie goal
I think that's what it's called yeah yeah pay pie goal I
don't know how I actually pronounce it but I bought a bunch
of those so I bought the little packet ones the spoon ones.
I hate dealing with the jars because they're so, it's so
like hard to clean because they're really sticky because the
thing, if you ever have sore throat or you have like vocal
issues, I highly recommend it because all professional
singers and professional singers and voice actors use it
because it actually works.
Like you literally just like take like I guess like a
spoonful and like in works for your throat because it coats
your throat with like a syrup and um and also like the next
day your throat basically feels like good as new um uh but
yeah i don't get the the jars because they're so sticky and
hard to clean um especially for the spoons too so i get the
little packet ones the travel size where you can just like
cut the packet and then you'll and then it's you're good and
then you don't have to worry about it anymore um and it's
just very convenient i'm I'm just very lazy and it's very
convenient for me.
Smug.
Wait, did I read?
I don't remember I read your super chat already, but I'll
read it again.
Merry Christmas, Doki and Dragombs.
Congratulations on 9JK again.
Doki, dear, so cute.
I got it.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Felice Navida.
Bomb, bomb.
Wow.
Oh yeah, it's almost Christmas in an hour for the Easties.
Please, Namita, have a great Christmas, Doki and Dragos.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys.
I do hope you guys have a wonderful, wonderful Christmas and
your holidays.
I do appreciate all those who are here right now to spend
there to, I guess, like, end the day, end your Christmas Eve
with me.
I really do appreciate it a lot.
All right.
Anyway, I do want to talk about the GSC that Xbox has
confirmed that the size of GTA 4 is 676 gigabytes.
I was like, holy fuck, like how, I don't own consoles
anymore, but like, if GTA 6 is 676 gigabytes, I'm, I'm
worried about that P, I assume they optimize it for PC, I
hope they optimize it for PC, because who the fuck has 676
gigabytes on their fucking, oh thank God, oh thank God, okay
guys.
Okay, I just...
Okay, guys, it's been debunked.
Okay, sorry.
I was spreading fake news.
I checked the tweet.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, Merry Christmas, everyone.
It's a Christmas miracle.
It just got debunked.
It literally...
I had this tweet open the entire day, trying to figure out
if this shit was real or not.
And because there was no fucking...
There was no...
There was no fucking...
What was it called?
The note?
Adding context thing.
What is it called the the fact it's a Christmas miracle.
Oh my yeah
Like when they add the the community note there was no
community note for fucking hours So I was like there's no
way and they got me they fucking got me.
I was like there's no fucking way that This is six hundred
and six seventy six gigabytes because I do I I do have that
amount of space But I have to use my other hard drive Oh my
god.
No, no, this guy, everyone was freaking out.
There was no community note for the longest time.
It just got community noted 11 hours ago.
Thank God.
It means spreading wisdom.
It's a Christmas miracle.
Now you feel better that it's not 676 gigabytes.
Ramona, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Hope everyone gets everything they wanted from saddening
again.
Congrats on 900k.
Thank you.
Thank you Also, NSD.
Thank you for the vibe.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Yeah, it freaked me out Um, because like people were like
freaking out in the replies to I was like, there's no
community Yeah, also, okay, but this one's real guys.
This one's real.
Did you guys see the the the souls like based on India?
I actually really want to play this game.
There's a new Souls-like game that's based off of India.
And it actually looks crazy good.
Yeah, when it's real, it was an AI.
People were like, oh my god.
No, the fight scene is fucking crazy.
Wait, I gotta show you guys the...
Because he makes poses every time he like...
I think every time he parries, he makes a fucking pose or
some shit.
Let me see if I can find it.
It's actually crazy.
I think it was this one.
It's like a fucking Bollywood.
Oh, it's here.
Okay, it's here.
Like those goddamn zoomins, like the Bollywood zoomins and
shit.
Okay, here.
Yeah, it's like he's literally aura farming.
I thought it was, I thought it was a AI at first.
Cause like the original video was like this random like 420
at 4, 4, 4, sorry.
What was the quality?
I'm going to look at it.
uh 240 it was like 240p on a tick tock video but this guy
like recorded the tick tock video on his phone and it was
like 240p quality so i assumed that it was ai but then
people in the comments were like no this is a real game and
i wish list it i actually wish list it and i found out they
linked an ign trailer of it and i instantly wish list it
fucking sick it actually looks really fun um but yeah i just
really wanted to uh i just really wanted to give you guys an
update also to you guys here we're gonna have the real oh
and not we but uh america's gonna have the the real hunger
games soon next year because um i wanted to talk about it
for the longest time but i thought it was so funny uh that
we're actually gonna get a real hunger games because you
know it's gonna get a lot of fucking views um but next year
because in 2026 because um it's america's 250th birthday and
also my birthday by the way i can't believe they're doing a
hunger games on my birthday we should actually watch it i
honestly no lie oh my god i know it's gonna be on a fucking
streaming service it's gonna be a goddamn on a streaming
service so i hope it's like public tv i hope it's not like i
hope it's not like paywall or anything because okay so
here's the context of the patriot game games.
Here's the context on the Patriot games.
So it was announced that next year they're going to have the
Patriot games to celebrate the 250th anniversary of the
United States of America.
And what they're doing is that each state is going to send
in one male and one female athlete, teenagers by teenage
female and male athlete to represent their state and and
they're all gonna compete for a multi-day event to see which
state has is the most athletic state well i don't know what
sports gonna be i want to be east where he's gonna be there
but finally the finally the actual hunger games so it's real
yeah and i'm like i actually low-key really want to watch it
on my birthday because i'm like thinking it must really suck
because i don't know a lot about american states but like i
was asking about my friends i was like which state do you
think is gonna like it must really suck to be the state that
wins nothing like because there's gonna be like 50 states
right 50 states that are going to send in their
representative so i'm like thinking which one would win
nothing i'm like i'm so i'm so curious okay and then i was
like okay i i i don't know because i'm not like i'm not
knowledgeable but like which state is the most athletic
at texas cali wait why texas cali or new york where
Wait, what's wrong with Texas?
Oh, wait.
Okay, wait.
Okay, there's going to be really fucked up.
I have to look up this.
I don't want to say it in case I fuck up.
Oh, wait.
That's not true.
Okay.
I was looking at...
Okay, I will tell you guys what I Googled.
I won't...
I'll be very transparent so you know I'm real.
I instantly Googled top states for obesity.
Okay.
Sorry, because the guys were like, Texas.
And I was like, oh, is that part of the, is that, are they
in the list?
I was like, I was like, are they on the list?
I was like, that's like, but they're not.
Texas isn't in there.
That's the first thought I thought of, because I was like,
why would you, why would Texas be like the worst performing
state?
It's not.
Rank one is West Virginia.
What about whopping 40?
Okay, wait, teenager.
Okay, I'll do like...
Most obese state for teenagers.
Because it's like, for adults, it's like, oh, it's still
West Virginia.
It's 24%.
Actually, no.
Mississippi is number two for adult obesity.
But Mississippi is number one for youth obesity.
But number, so West Virginia is number one.
for adults, but number two for the youths.
So, like, you guys are battling it out.
Uh, nothing to do in West Virginia, but eat.
Any West Virginians?
I mean, that food must be really good, right?
In West Virginia?
Any West Virginians in my chat that can vouch for that?
Um, I used to play college balling.
No, it It's not, like, but you would assume the food is
really good, though.
Omnistate, maybe.
You don't need good food at all, damn.
Wait, is West Virginia?
Is that where the corn comes from?
Is that where the...
Okay, for those in one context, I was trying to...
to figure out where the corn comes from in America.
My initial thought was Kansas because of, for those who
didn't watch the Haiti stream, I was like, oh, does corn
come from Kansas?
Because my, where I got that from is from Wizard of Oz.
And when Dorothy is like, oh, we're not in Kansas no more.
So that's why I know she's from Kansas.
And then like, she lives on a farm and on that farm is just
all corn.
So I would assume that the corn grows in Kansas because, you
know, that corn.
But do they also grow them corn in West Virginia?
Plenty of corn in India.
Oh, I know about that.
I know Indiana loves their corn too.
Also, I don't know geography.
No, 100% do not know much about.
I feel like I know more about European countries than I do
about geography of my own country and America.
Jesus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There are many points.
Oh my god.
They got low obesity and high altitude.
Oh, that's true.
Colorado is where all the mountains are.
I don't even know this because I used to watch the creatures
and they used to live in Colorado.
Also, apparently really cheap taxes.
Oh, I found out.
I found out a lot of place.
A lot.
I was like wondering.
I was like, why is everything filmed in like Atlanta slash
Georgia?
I was so confused because like I was looking up like, I was
looking up like movies.
uh films and tv show and film are only filmed in like three
places it's like alanta slash georgia uh uh vancouver and uh
one more i don't remember what it was film play most common
places to film oh yeah it's because of taxes it's because
the government pays you too uh Which one was it?
In Toronto?
And I was like reading it.
Because like apparently for Georgia.
Because like Stranger Things.
Was filmed in Georgia.
Yeah.
So I was like super surprised about that.
A lot of famous TV shows.
Is actually filmed in.
Um.
In like Vancouver or Georgia.
And.
Um.
And I was like reading up on it.
Because I've always won.
Because like.
Uh.
Apparently in.
For America.
The Georgia government.
Pays them to pays the people to film like to make films in
their state.
So, I mean, that's smart, you know, it's good it's good
tourism too.
Yeah, apparently it's like really good tourism.
And then and then the reason why they choose Vancouver for
filming is because you can make Vancouver look like America.
I thought it was like, oh, it's it's they're so America
passing.
Yeah, and also taxes too.
It's apparently like the least taxed country.
It's why everyone moved to Texas for one point because like,
you guys might not, I don't know if you guys might notice
this, but a couple of years ago, almost every con, before
there was LA, every content creator would live in Texas,
like every, all the content creators because like it had the
cheapest taxes for entertainers.
So that's why they do that because they get taxed at least.
They love to do like, you know, tax evasion and shit like
that.
Yeah, Texas is incredibly cheap, but so fucking hot.
Yeah, so I thought it was really interesting.
And then I was reading it.
They're like, oh, yeah, Vancouver has like mountains, lakes,
and the city.
So they'll be like, all right, we can literally pretend
they're traveling everywhere, but they're just in one area.
I was just like, that's so smart.
They're like, all right, they're like, all right, we're
going to go to a different state, but they're still in
Vancouver.
Like, they just changed the perspective of where they're
filming.
Like, that's so fucking smart.
Shadow, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, Merry Christmas, and thank you for another amazing
year filled with your contagious laughter and whimsy.
Hope you have a good Christmas and get some good food.
Merry Christmas to all dragons also.
Stay safe, everyone, and enjoy your day.
Thank you for the magenta soup, thank you, thank you.
Wait, Texas is banning anime?
Wait, is that true?
When did that happen?
Extra, extra.
Read all about it.
Texas says no more anime women.
Could a new Texas law.
Oh, it's just...
They're not actually banning anime, guys.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'm not reading this article.
no no it's not anime it's mostly ai it's you know what they
were trying to ban they're trying to ban ai pornography
that's it's not the same guys it's it's not the same um
chicago thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
exactly why for a moment the twin heads they actually call
it New Hollywood for all the Philly names filmed there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's not...
Alright.
Apparently they said that it could be grouped into it.
I don't think so.
I think it's fine.
There's no way because there's a big anime convention in
Texas.
I don't remember what it's called, but I remember there is a
big anime convention there.
Oh my, did I see the video of the guy being like...
is what if mario was made by triple a my triple a game
publisher oh my god i wish i owned it i saved it that shit
was so good listen m wait mario focus m that shit was so
okay here you go
and there's people who haven't read it who haven't listened
to it yet it's actually so cringe But it's so, it's cringe
in a way where it's like, it's too real that I cringed at
it.
It was the most Chris Pratt dialogue.
But Mario is Triple A.
Um, wait, um, if Mario was invented, uh, this year, maybe
that's a better phrase.
It's like, what if Mario was invented this year by a Triple
A publisher?
That's not Nintendo.
Focus him.
It's so good.
It's actually so good.
I still can't believe we're getting a real hunger games.
You know, that's going to get so many.
Oh my god, so many people are going to be watching.
I swear to God, if it's not public access, like, they
must...
Like, I swear to God, if this is paywall for the Patriot
games, I would be so fucking sad.
It's like every state is participating so it's like it
should be like streamed on YouTube like I just want to know
I just I just I want to be there like don't pay like are
they gonna pay Oh my god, it's gonna be like Saturday.
It's gonna be like every fucking American TV show where you
can't watch We it's like Saturday Night Live because you
can't Canadians are part of Saturday apparently
C holds the rights to the Patriot Games.
Just like the Olympics.
I swear to God.
I remembered like, um, I think I was like traveling in
America or some shit.
I think like when one Olympics was going on and it's like
region locked to, it was, it's like not region locked, but
you know, you can only watch it on one network because they
own the rights to the Olympics.
It's gonna be paid.
Oh, yeah, speaking of, I saw someone mention about gambling.
Um, but like, but like, bro, Jake Paul made so much fucking
money from the box.
Bro, like, I mean, maybe, I mean, he's not getting those
brain cells back, but he doesn't matter.
He made 66 million dollars.
Like, did you guys hear that?
They're like, bro, that match was so fucking rigged, bro.
Like, that, uh, yeah, like, Um, for those who don't know,
uh, Jake Paul did a boxing match with, like, a fucking
number one number one boxers, uh, of our time, um, and,
like, one of the, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know,
I'm not really into boxing, um, but, like, you know,
everyone saw the memes, you know, it's crazy that he smiled,
though, when he fucking punched his ass, um, but, basically,
I'm, he, he makes, I think, like, around, Oh my god, let me
I sent I sent this to someone Let me get the link for it
Because like I was telling this to one of my friends Because
they were like talking about the boxing match I was like,
you know that match is rigged, right?
And he's like, what do you mean by rigged?
And I'm like, bro The longer Jake Paul stays alive Like
alive?
That's the wrong way to phrase it But, oh, I didn't send the
link, but the longer he survives per round, the more he gets
paid.
I think it was like, it was like 5.5 million per round.
So, um, by him, because like, everyone was like, there's no
way he would last the six rounds.
Like, just, like, you could tell he was just fucking running
away.
He's got, God was so fucking scared.
Wait, I must have saved it, so wait, let me check.
I'm gonna check.
I know I like sent this to someone because I thought that
shit was so funny There's like a screenshot There's like a
screenshot of like him like running away and everything.
It was so fucking funny Let me see I could find it And like
he looked like the hamster The fucking scared ass hamster.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I don't think I oh my god.
I did not book market um but it's it's such a good picture
if i could ever find it i'll be so happy but like uh but
that guy made 66 million dollars for lasting six rounds
that's why i was like there's no fucking way that he legit
lasted he like that was all legit i i refused to believe
that he did this legit i guess that guy was a fucking pussy
when it came to boxing it's popular okay jake office boxing.
Well, do you think he's going to DMCA me?
There's no way he cares.
Oh, yeah, there he goes.
I found it.
All right.
Where is it?
I love this picture.
It's so good.
This picture is actually so good.
Okay.
I'm saving it.
And I'll show you guys.
It's a little blurry, but like, You get the image.
Where did I save it?
Where the fuck did I save it?
Okay, there you go.
Look at this.
I love that face.
That's so good.
That's how he was during the entire fight.
The guy's like, like, this guy looks like he's like, I'm not
breaking a sweat, bro.
I'm just getting started.
I'm like, bro, there's no way.
This last that is a legit six rounder.
There's No, this smile isn't edited.
The edited one is where he like The edited one is like where
he perks his eyebrows But that's that and like the smile is
more prominent.
This one is not edited This is like his legit face when he
was doing the punching.
I saw the edited version because I thought that was real But
then people were like no no this is actually the real feel.
Yeah, this is the unedited one by the way The edited one is
he's like he does the he does the DreamWorks eyes.
He does like I can't do it on my face.
He does the dream work face in the editor one.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
That's so cute.
Thank you, the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Merry Christmas to my favorite streamer and all the lovely
dragoons here.
I think we work on the holidays, but I hope y'all enjoyed
yourself.
Thank you.
Thank you, the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
much yeah if like jake paul got paid i'm i swear he like did
a split i swear he split like the 66 million with him or
some shit there's no fucking way that's real there's no
fucking way that's why everyone's like that shit is rigged
also i've been i forgot to keep talking about this because i
um i've been wanting to talk about this for a very long time
um but i keep forgetting about it but do you guys know about
the fucking boy band called boy throb Okay, I'm sorry, that
shit is like been stuck in my head for so long So I don't
know if you guys ever saw the famous the viral clip of this
like Um of this random boy band dancing in a retirement home
and their fourth member is like on the PC Dancing with them
so like that shit has been like That shit has been like
stuck in my head for so long so this shit was like a legit
it came from so um and then i swear to god it's all satire
from this but like and i found out that this they have a
tick tock account this group has a tick tock it's so funny
i'm sorry i watched like almost all their videos but it's so
funny because because they're like trying to get their
friend like his name was like danish danish or something
wait what's his name what is his name their fourth members
in India.
I'm Darshan.
Okay, so Darshan's fourth member is like, yeah, it's like
literally, it's like Little New Island.
So their fourth member is Darshan from India.
And they keep like green screening.
They would like green screen in the video.
They're like, um, like, we're trying to get Darshan a visa
so he can come perform for us.
Perform with us in America.
Sorry, Doki.
I found my new Oshi.
And his name is Darshan.
No, I swear it's actually, I don't know.
I think it's so fucking funny.
Because, like, apparently two of them, two of them have been
trying, like, trying to actually make a music career for,
like, years.
For, like, five-plus years.
And they've been, like, constantly auditioning for American
Idol, like, non-stop, but would never get on TV.
So they're like, we're going to create our own boy pen
called Boy Throb.
Apparently, they asked the internet to be like, oh, what
should we be called?
And I think like, oh yeah, they're like, what name should we
call them?
And of course, the internet being the internet suggests a
really, really bad name for them as their first choice.
That's their first choice.
So they went with their second choice.
I don't know if I could say what their first choice was.
It might be related to some files.
So, I can't really say what the first choice is.
But their second choice was boy throb.
Rise with, it might be a file of some sort.
And then, apparently, their immigration lawyer was like, do
not name your bandit or we will not be able to get a visa
for Darshan.
So they were like, okay, we're going to be the boy throb.
Which at least, it's not, it's bad.
But not as bad as the first choice that the viewers voted
for.
Um, but like, it's been like, I swear to God, like, this
shit has been, like, on my mind.
Because they're like, please get us a million, a million
subscribe followers so we could get Darshan a visa.
And literally, they made their account two months ago.
They got a million followers in two months.
That's fucking crazy.
But like, so people, so the two of the members.
were like super serious about actually singing and dancing
and creating a boy band but they could like never get in so
they're like fuck this we're just gonna make like a comedy
group and it's working it's actually working also that their
third member is a lawyer he's like hello i'm and i'm a
lawyer and i'm like what did the tall guy
honestly true the fucking darshan buff i could it's just i
don't know i just it's been like on my mind.
I've actually been following them because it's just fucking
so stupid.
If it works, it works, you know.
Bro, they gotta get, bro, they gotta get him a visa, bro.
Yeah, I wanna see them.
I wanna see them at a, being an opener at a concert.
They outsourced their fourth member.
That's like crazy.
Wait, I told you!
I told doing so fucking good
Oh my god So Darshan can come into America
Oh, yeah, they do they have an official music they they
actually released their first song And I would have to say
their first song is actually a banger Like it's not like
satire at all.
It's actually a legit song uh go thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you um hi doki my birthday yesterday uh
my dear birthday sorry my dear my birthday was yesterday
could i get a happy birthday from you also merry christmas
and thank you for all entertainment this year thank you the
super chat go thank you thank you i hope you have a great
christmas and a great birthday yesterday of course i can
wish you a happy birthday happy birthday to you you happy
birthday dear girl oh happy birthday to you yeah happy
birthday yeah oh what else i want to talk about oh my god
did you guys know babies were born flat like their heads i
was i did not know i booked like this on my twitter because
i was like what because like not only for the fun fact by
the way um but um oh my god i have several fun facts that i
learned on twitter my education from twitter now um my
algorithm i don't know what the fuck is up with my algorithm
um all right thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you looks like you found four members for your v12 cover
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you okay so um
here's some fun facts about uh about giving birth so
apparently um this is what i talked about before but um but
you poop little when it happens because they don't tell you
that the doctors don't tell you that the shows don't tell
you this you know how i learned about this from saturday
night live and when i found out i was like you poop when you
get burned so like some of you guys might be poop babies
just so you know your mother's will never tell you i don't
know if they'll ever But some of us were poop babies.
Yeah.
So, because, you know, you're pushing.
So, anyway.
Anyway.
I found out recently.
Poop babies are stronger.
I've decided.
Oh, look at him.
Mr. Fancy Fass being a C-section baby.
Oh, Mr. Fancy.
man over here gets to be cut open from the belly anyway
anyway so I found out about this like a couple of days ago
but baby heads were born flat usually because if you're if
your moms are always like lying down during pregnancy um all
the weight of the baby's head would like distribute like
horizontally so so because of that um and like because of
that a lot of babies heads are born flat and for the first
couple of months it's super malleable that's why you're not
supposed by the way do not poke a baby's head that's and
their head and skull is like super squishy so because of
that um if the baby is always lying down they will have a
fucking long ass head so if whose head is super long and
flat, they were a lazy baby.
They hurt.
So, because, like, they're supposed to be sitting upright.
They're mostly, like, you're supposed to be sitting upright.
Or, apparently, parents are supposed to buy these fucking
helmets for babies to wear, to, like, physically shape,
don't be me, to physically shape their heads to be a round
size.
I was so surprised because I was like, what the fuck do you
mean?
Like, like, apparently doctors would be like compliment,
will compliment babies by being like, wow, your baby's head
was born so round.
Good for you.
And I'm like, what the fuck does that mean?
Like, I guess I would read that.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
Are baby's heads not supposed to be round?
What shape are they supposed to be?
And yeah, so like, babe, like some parents will spend like
hundreds of dollars to make sure their baby's head is round
so yeah so wait let me show you guys the photo of it
apparently costs hundreds of dollars dude i was like what
the fuck let me see oh yeah here we go yeah 700 $100
helmets.
Yeah, so they have to wear these, like, headgear to, like, I
like how they're, like, passables.
Yeah, I didn't realize they're real.
Yeah, you gotta optimize your child.
It's because you're...
That's why babies...
You have to, like, Make sure the baby isn't lying down and
mostly sitting upright.
So your head isn't like, your head isn't like, you know,
fucking being spilled over.
You gotta customize the baby.
Yeah, because if they're lying down too much, the head is
just flat as fuck.
Like, so I was like, hope your baby's doing okay.
Wait, can you bonsai tree or a baby?
That's what they used to do in the old days.
We don't do that anymore because apparently it's frowned
upon by society.
No, it's actually true.
I think it was the Incas.
I think, or the Aztec times.
But back in the day, people would like shape their head,
like shape baby's heads into like...
Oh, it's Peruvian.
Okay.
They would shape it into like an actual alien head where it
would be like...
Would be like really tall or some shit.
Yeah.
Yeah, so it's like, yeah, apparently it's legal now.
It's like found upon the society.
I don't know why, though.
Yeah, like people used to, like, back then, people did shape
their baby's heads.
Because they were like, whoa, we can make it in any shape we
want.
like for the ancient meme that reminds me there's this guy
that that uh built a handsome squidward statue and then left
it the body of the ocean to freak out future uh future
scientists or anthropologists that is such a fucking great
prank like no i it's just i it just sucks that he won't live
to see the result it's just well i wish i could like be
immortal just to see how react to that prank that shit is so
good
the longest cognac generational trolling like they're kids
kids kids like and then he should like write a piece of
letter to his future uh great great great great great great
grand kid to be like open this letter when they find the
statue in the ocean and it's just and then the kid will be
like oh my god this letter has been passed down by great
grandfather and like we never knew what he meant by that but
it finally happened and then the letter would be like ha got
him it's just yeah it's yeah it's just got him
that makes me so paranoid that not paranoid but it makes me
wonder like did they do anything to fuck with us like now
like like the the people in the during the year old times
what did they oh yeah it's like it's like the graffiti um at
pompey there's like there's like a famous graph there's like
famous uh graffities on the pompey walls and one of them was
like uh fuck this whore i remember yeah so like yeah one of
the people is like fuck this bitch whore and then like their
her name on
Yeah, at Pompeii, yeah.
There was shitposting.
The ye old Roman shitposting graffiti.
Damn, okay.
That's dumb.
Yeah, the Roman shitpost.
Yeah, bro was mad as fuck back then.
Yeah, the real Pompeii disaster.
The one with the volcano and stuff.
Yeah, we shall always remember as that bitch whore.
oh yeah another fun fact you know okay so what's called
epidermal oh is it is that what it's called so like there's
like drugs where that for like pregnant women uh when
they're about to give birth they give it to them um so that
it's not as painful yeah epidermal did you know that goes to
your spine i thought it was iv shit you know You fucking
they just insert it in your IV bag and then and then like it
just slowly goes into your like wrist Yeah, so like they
fucking stab you on your back and it's very it's a very deep
needle too I did not know this it was like on Twitter.
You're like what the fuck do you mean?
That's the epidural I was like what?
That that needle was so long.
I saw like a gift of it and like and it's right into your
spine I'm too, I'm too much of a bro, you know, like For the
so god I know this, you know Homies don't tell other homies
How
How the hospital stuff works I didn't know the estate, dude
You should know this especially.
Yeah, bro, I'm cute.
I did not know about this.
Yeah, it's long as fuck.
And it was like, I was like, it didn't stop.
I was just like, bro, what the fuck?
It was like, and the needle kept going.
I was like, holy fuck.
A bro helps deliver their bro's baby.
Oh, you're a better bro than me, bro.
yeah no that was another fun fact i wanted you guys to know
it's very important i'm keeping you guys prepared
so you won't be surprised you know i'm making sure you guys
won't be surprised if your baby is a poop baby then like you
know it's it's okay it happens to everyone well not everyone
the Kids think they're all that Thanks, Tokey I don't But I
don't bum But lots of fun facts today, guys Oh, man, also
Sorry, I have a lot of fun things to share For you guys Um
Um, you have to No, I'm an only child Uh, well, glad you're
on this topic.
Oh, the flathead babies.
I was like, wait, you got do you have to wear helmets?
I was like, that surprised me so much.
But I found out babies have to wear helmets to make sure
they're not shamed for their flat ass head that they're born
with.
Next, see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lots of fun facts about pregnancy this stream.
Are you planning to sing Santa Baby or something?
Thank you in the super chat thank you day oh yeah here's a
um another fun fact but um a japanese student has invented
an anti-cheating smart bra bra which unlocks only with a
boyfriend's fingerprint and i was like how the does that
like prevent cheating i can't see this that's just crazy
Yeah, it's a real ass bra to unlocks with the fingerprint.
It doesn't.
Like, it's just 50% done.
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, tech bros wouldn't invent anything.
Bro never has to worry about that.
problem you peasants couldn't get a c-section my my brother
and i were too thick so the healthiest damn you were thick
you were thick as hell also gumball the new gumball series
uh they added skibby the toilet in the new gumball episode i
don't know if you guys saw that because i had to see it you
guys have to look at it too this is a fun christmas eve
stream for me
at it so and i wondered michael bay got paid royalties on it
also another fun fact though but um apparently the kim
kardashian fortnite skin is the most used skin in um uh for
chapter seven fortnite season i'm like what kim kardashian
skin of all the skins um that got released in chapter seven
it's the kim kardashian skin that is the The most used one.
That actually blew my mind.
You know she made millions off of that too.
I mean, it's also the first...
To be fair, I will say it's the first Fortnite skin to bring
back boobs.
I remember I told you guys this, but for those who didn't
know, when they got more family friendly, they literally
covered up everybody.
They were like all the Fortnite skins that had even a little
bit of is showing they covered it up they literally patch
the hole up so like everyone's like oh my god kim
kardashians they brought it back they brought back the boobs
oh my god what would the children
think before yeah so like there would be like a fortnight
skins where there would be like boop windows and everything
because it's like part of the design like the original
design or some Or like they would have show like just a
little line, you know a little bit of the line and then And
then fortnight went through the family friendly phase and
they literally patched the hole They like added like they
just covered it up like it's like Fox kids or some shit.
Yeah It's like they got like you know like when Fox kids
when they like edit the like edit the clips and everything
then patch up all the violence and the guns where they
replace guns with like bats or some shit in four kids or
like oh my god I think my favorite part was when I think it
was like a one I think it was one piece or some shit I think
it was like it was a Zoro where she was like crucified or
something and then and then and then four kids was like we
can't show the cross on anime on a kid show we can't compare
him we can't compare Zoro to Jesus Christ We got it.
We got to cover up the cross.
Yeah I was like that one was my favorite I was like they
literally censored the cross They're like not you're not
Jesus we can't let you have that.
Oh, yeah, no cigarette to a lollipop I will say Well, uh,
four kids did one thing right and that was giving anime some
Bangor intros.
You can't change my mind.
They're very iconic.
The one-piece rap.
It was a banger.
I know they.
Bro, okay.
Anime, English.
Adap English intros.
We're so fucking iconic, though.
Like, instead of butterfly, we got Digimon, Digital
Monsters.
Like, and it just, it's literally just, like, six words
repeated non-stop.
And it was iconic as hell.
Digimon, the champions, Digimon, did.
Digimon are the...
Digital champions
Change into digital to save the digital world I love that
that fire where they're like To save the digital world
That shit was good It was, it truly was, they were truly
bangers.
Oh yeah, did you guys see the, um, they like, I was a Dragon
Ball Z Kai, what was the fighting game?
They were, apparently people are freaking out about this
modder that released a Yu-Gi-Oh mod in the Dragon Ball Z
fight.
And it looked so good.
I was watching, I was like, what the fuck is this?
actually it fucking goes hard it looks sick like he just
like you start spamming cards and shit like it's an actual
Dragon Ball Z fighter mod where you can play Yu-Gi-Oh yeah
and there's also other there's other ones too where you can
summon the sky dragon and the exodia he literally summons
the I trust everything to this card.
Now, Exodia's seal has been broken.
Behold, it's gorgeous free.
Exodia, it was an obliterate.
And then it's fucking Cell.
And then he fucking kills Cell.
It's crazy.
I think Exodia one was the fucking...
It was the fucking craziest one.
Monster card.
Monster card!
I wish mods like affects the opponent too.
Oh my god, that would be so tilting.
Thank you so much.
Monster card!
Neppers!
Thank you for the magenta soup but thank you, thank you!
Memorable Pompei quo.
We too dear men.
Friends for ever we're here if you want to know my our names
there gas and aluus words for life awesome merry christmas
everyone thank you for the magenta soup thank you thank you
yeah there are some um there are some banger quotes uh at
the pompey graffiti it's weird the romans knew how to
graffiti i remember like people like our uh anthropologists
were like or it was anthropologists were like oh man i
wonder what these these uh text mean it must be very like
civilized and like uh uh like oh man a glimpse into their
lives and it's literally like people shit posting on walls
like nothing's changed chikori thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you well i thought one thought it's just
sanji case makes sense because coke with smoke thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you how often do you think
about the roman emperor bro all the time man All the fucking
time.
Yeah, we are the same people.
We've never changed.
Yeah, every day.
Every time I close my eyes, I think about the Roman Empire.
And then even when my eyes are open, I still think about the
Roman Empire.
Oh yeah, I saw this tweet.
Today is just me showing you guys tweets.
I saved up that I wanted to tell you guys about.
Um, I should have saved it up for tomorrow, but like, today
I really want to show you guys the funny tweets.
Because my algorithm's a mess.
My 4U page is a fucking mess.
Bite, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy Christmas, Doki Claus.
All I want for Christmas is you under my tree.
Thank you for the super chat, and then I'll rob you.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, here's my social media.
Here's what my algorithm looks like, and that's why you know
when you know why I'm like this.
So I saw this tweet.
I saw this tweet like a couple of days ago.
What?
Yeah, two days ago.
Because like, if anyone watched for NAF2, William Afton,
like, is in a dream sequence, and he falls back, but like,
they filmed it, like, upright.
And I was like, wait, that's fucking funny.
And someone in the Twitter was like, why the fuck didn't he
like fall on an actual green mat?
And my favorite reply to it was like, because he'll always
come back.
So I was like, because he'll die.
And so I was like, but he'll always come back.
I was like, that's so fucking good, bro.
That's so good.
Also because, yeah, no, this guy's old.
Like, he's gonna fucking break his neck or some shit.
Yeah, it's his thing.
The FNAF 2 movie failed.
It's better than FNAF 1.
No, FNAF 1 was so fucking stupid.
I'm sorry.
I, you cannot change my mind.
There were so many plot holes in FNAF 1.
But FNAF 2 made...
I love the part.
where it got into like Godzilla versus King Kong so there is
a scene I'll give you guys a little there's a spoiler
warning but there's a scene where it's like the old at the
FNAF 1 animatronics versus FNAF 2 animatronics I swear to
God it felt like Godzilla versus King Kong where they're
just like they like they start fucking it wasn't even a
fight it was really like FNAF 1 people like fucking the FNAF
1 animatronics like ripping apart the FNAF 2 animatronics
but it was so So fucking stupid.
Yeah, it's like a Kaiju death match, but it lasted like five
seconds.
This ruined Christmas.
How does this not sound more stupid than FNAF one?
Because FNAF 2 didn't have the fucking scene where the child
was like, I know how to stop them.
Drew a picture of the animatronics ripping apart William
Afton and It pinned it on the fucking wall and then it
worked like there was no fucking Foreshadowing or lead up to
this.
I'm like how the fuck did you figure this out like?
I was just like how the fuck did this child figure that's so
stupid.
It's so stupid.
It's been months, but I'll still that that part Still gets
me It's so fucking stupid.
Oh, yeah and the aunt lives by the way the aunt is alive
they never show her again they just said oh yeah she's
fucking she was crazy and now she's like committed to a
mental asylum by the way because she's like i saw the
animatronics and they try to kill me and like it was just
like um exposition dump where they're trying to be like what
happened to the aunt and they're like oh yeah she's like in
the mental asylum now like she's she's like in rehab right
now because everyone
but they say in the very beginning of the FNAF 2 movie
because that's what everyone was wondering they were like
what the fuck happened to the uh to the odd I will have to
say I don't understand like okay I haven't watched uh you
know how like like Blumhouse is like the um the forefront uh
the forefront for like horror movies now like they are like
everyone like goes to them for like the hold on all the
current generation of the current horror movie characters i
have no idea how what's her name the fucking dancing robot
is like a horror character i don't know to be fair i've only
seen the trailers but even then the trailers portray her as
like comedic as like it's like a comedy trailer where she
fucking starts dancing and everything Megan yes is it Megan
the robot like but she's like plastered everywhere as like
the next horror icon and I'm like okay like she is iconic
yeah fuck you like it's like it's not a horror I swear to
God I should try and watch it but like I would assume the
first movie was more horror geared and then after that it
becomes like a comedy movie yeah it feels like an action
comedy film because like there was a trailer i think it was
like a trailer where um blumhouse did a collab with was it
pepsi or mountain was it pepsi or mountain dew but they did
a collab with like all of blumhouse's uh most popular horror
films and it was like finnaf um the phone call one oh fanta
sorry they are by the way you guys didn't know a lot of the
soda companies are owned by like one or two companies.
Nesty, I think Nesty is owned by Coke, right?
I know Fanta is owned by like either Pepsi or Coke.
It's one of them.
They literally have a monopoly on soda.
Yeah.
And then like, it was like Blackphone, FNAV, and Megan.
And I forgot the fourth one was Jason, right?
Yeah.
So, and then I'm like, how the fuck is... Oh yeah, Chucky.
It was Chucky.
Yeah.
Chucky was there and I'm like how the fuck is bro Megan
thinks she's part of the team like every time I see Megan
she's just fucking dancing I don't understand I don't
understand she's just dancing how is she horror why is she
grouped up with all of them this girl thinks she's part of
the team
for those who don't know Megan I'll show you guys the
trailer it's not even the thing is it's not even a scary
dance Megan oh shit sorry uh oh no what did i press oh there
we go sorry rgb time
all right where is it
where the fuck is the i mean i can't see she murders a guy
but even then It's not even scary!
Like...
Yeah, she murders!
But she just starts...
And then she...
And the thing is, she...
She dances all the time now!
What the fuck?
There's no way this is an official.
Murder is not scary, apparently, from Doki Bird.
She's emoting!
Bro, that's so true.
It's fucking emoting.
Palapar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's through Nestle, Coca-Cola, and Pepsi.
Yeah, none of them own each other.
Yeah, also like, what was it?
I know like, wait, water company owned by Coke.
What was it?
The seat, Dasani.
Dasani is owned by Coca-Cola.
They also own water, too.
And Pepsi owns Aquafina.
That's why you have Aquafina versus Dasani.
Oh yeah, Pepsi is greedy.
They have like four different water companies.
What the fuck?
Why do you need four water companies?
One of them will work.
Yeah, they own water.
Yeah, Pepsi owns four different water companies.
Dasani is the worst water.
started using AI for their ads.
It's not even good AI, it's too.
It's actually pretty bad.
The ads are terrible.
I miss like, I miss when Coca-Cola actually paid lots of
money.
Like, actually, like, have really good ads.
But to be fair, I'm, like, thinking, I think they don't care
about ads anymore because they have such a huge monopoly on,
like, water, like, not just water, like, on water and soda.
So I think, like, they don't really need to sell Coke
because everyone buys Coke now.
Like, like, people go to Coke anyway, so, so, like, they
don't really, yeah, they don't even need to, like, actually
advertise it.
Not anymore, so they don't care anymore.
Because back then, it was always Coke versus Pepsi, but I
don't think people really drink Pepsi anymore.
Yeah, they won, it's like the console wars, but they won.
It's like how PlayStation won the console wars against Xbox.
And then PC just rolls up and...
And PC Master Race...
Oh!
Sorry, that's from Flash Kids.
Yeah.
Sorry, that was a Flash Kids quote if anyone watches the
console wars.
Okay, love that video.
I'm one of the Master Race PC Master Race.
I hope you'll always be happy.
Love, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Not A9.
Thank you.
Don't say that.
Oh my God.
Zero punctuation.
That's a throwback.
I actually used to watch those videos too before it like,
before they like exploded.
Because their company was really bad or some shit.
Yeah.
pretty sure like i think it's just like coca-cola one so
they don't care anymore uh koi welcome to tomato farm
welcome welcome yeah they imploded yeah escapist yeah i feel
like it's because like nobody reads gaming blogs anymore at
that time like yeah like literally the only thing that was
keeping them relevant was zero punctuation um but even then
they were like slowly falling off um then people would like
you know back then people don't really use social media they
just like they they just browse like kotaku oh my god kotaku
i actually used to browse kotaku all the time when i was
younger um is everyone would just literally just go on
gaming blogs and everything and then now everyone just looks
at twitter like me just a filthy twitter user i would look i
would read kotaku for gaming news because that was like the
only place for me to get gaming news.
It was literally the only place for me to get gaming news,
guys.
And also April Fool's.
I'll go to Kotaku.
Just like, especially for April Fool's.
Just to be like, what did companies do on April Fool's?
What?
It was the thing back then.
What do you mean?
I don't do it anymore.
It was a thing back then, guys.
Oh,
man.
There was something I wanted to talk about.
Wait, let me second.
Remember.
It was like during the middle of my Megan rant.
I was like thinking about it.
I don't remember.
Hey, Mario.
Let me get a large double olive pizza.
Scotty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How was it?
I don't remember.
remember
I was the target audience
I think like speaking of that speaking of like the console
wars I think people might go back to console because it's
just not like PC gaming will become like what's so weird
it'll be like just catered to the people can afford it
people with the spending money to afford it.
I think, yeah, it's, yeah, because it's like, it'll be like,
it's not affordable anymore.
I don't know, I feel like, I feel like, does console use RAM
too?
How much, I mean, obviously, yeah, but like, it doesn't use
as much RAM, right?
Or is it luxury?
Oh, I thought they used less RAM versus PC.
What game?
Oh, no.
No, my Marvel arrival queues will be longer.
No!
Yeah, I think gaming's gonna be a luxury soon.
It's over.
I gotta wait long queues because there's not enough people
playing games.
You ever read about that?
Bro, I was saying earlier that You can literally...
I feel like you can scalp RAM from Costco.
I'm buying a pre-built PC.
Pop the AI bubble.
The bubble will eventually burst one day.
Just like NFTs.
It'll happen.
Just like NFTs, guys.
Not coping.
No, there's some...
I was at Costco.
I did a Costco run.
And, like, the, it, like, says it includes the RAM.
It was, like, only $1,000.
It was, like, 32 gigabytes of RAM.
And I swear to God, I'm pretty sure people...
They just hide the RAM.
They, like, unplugged the RAM from the display PCs.
Because I saw the RAM was gone.
And again, you're becoming a Netflix subscription service.
Oh, my God.
Remember to put on your tinfoil hat.
They're listening.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, there was like this test There was this test That
Where they were doing a thing Where they're testing you If
you know if If you know that This name was Was a drug or a
Pokemon Because it was made by this like Doctor from
pharmacy who was obsessed with Pokemon And they're like See
if you can figure Girl, which one's a Pokemon and which was
a drug?
And I looked at it.
I was like, there's no way these Pokemon names are real.
That's like, okay, to be fair, I did not pay attention to
the last two generations.
But I was like, bro, these names look like fucking AI
generated, I swear.
But they're real.
I was so surprised.
Wait, I'll show you guys.
Let's see if you guys...
Let's see if I can get rid of the answers.
Is that the...
Where's the picture?
Oh no.
Whoops.
Where the fuck is the image?
Where's this picture?
What am I holding here?
Oh my god.
Give me a sec guys.
I might have messed up.
I clicked on the wrong source file
Alright, there we go
Yeah, I looked at this And I was like What the fuck
I only recognized For the Pokemon names I was like Reller
Reller
really I looked at this and I legitimately only recognized
one Pokemon on here and it was fucking a Q font I don't even
oh not sorry not Q font it was Deoncy because it was like
that fucking rock Pokemon right her roller the goat not my
way it's Braxton oh wait there's Brad oh my god see Braxon.
Yeah, Braxon.
Yeah, I see Braxon and Deoncy.
I was like, I was like, what the fuck?
I thought it was a silly.
I thought it was a fun test.
Besant DPT is cheating.
That's a Pokemon.
That's cheating.
Bro, they named it.
They named this.
What you mean is cheating.
What the fuck is this?
Poison fairy?
Oh my god.
I...
I don't know.
Alright, welcome to the stream.
Thank you for this so much for the raid.
Thank you.
That's... That's Felie.
What's his name?
Fizondi PT.
the fuck what does that even mean what the fuck does that
mean is there any like hidden meaning behind that
yeah it's poison fairy what is the meaning oh it's like
peasant and serendipity okay oh
fezonti fezontipity oh my god they're like I'm going to
create a new word, but it's going to sound, it's going to be
like, pheasant.
Pheasant, oh my, they're like, it's pheasant, but spelled
with an F.
That's actually so, oh my God, that's so stupid.
I'm sorry, that's so fucking dumb.
Pheasant, pheasant, pheasant to pity.
dog no way no you're fucking with me oki dog is it oki doggy
is this supposed to be oki oki doki is that wait is oki doki
is supposed to be oki doki yes it's real oki doki oki doki
they're supposed to be oki Okie dokie.
Okay, that's good.
I like that one.
That's that.
I have no idea.
I guess like he's a dog.
He has this donkey.
But like I have no idea what what else does it imply.
That's beautiful.
Okie dokie.
He's poison fighting.
I mean, he looks poisonous.
Okay.
monkey dory oh my god i keep i feel like you're like with me
but i know they're real because it's a monkey monkey dory
jesus christ
oh my gosh oh man all right guys i'm gonna call it here chat
Merry Christmas to everyone on the East Coast right now.
Merry Christmas to you guys all.
And Merry Christmas to all the people on the other side of
the world.
Happy Christmas Eve.
And happy holidays to people in the West Coast.
Because it's not Christmas yet for us.
But thank you all for hanging out with me today.
For my Good Night Dragoons stream.
We went through a lot of different random tasks.
today I was like showing you guys my I'm just showing you
guys my stupid Twitter post and like giving you guys some
fun facts today but I'll guys enjoy hanging out with me as
always I had a great time hanging out my dragoons and I hope
you guys have a great holiday with your family and friends
or just with me and the dragoons I really appreciate you
guys hanging out tomorrow will be a very So I'll see you
guys there tomorrow.
I got a lot of stuff to do today to prep for it because I'm
not truly started prepping anything for like any of my
scenes and stuff and assets for it.
So I'll be doing that right after the stream ends.
And also for my 900K celebration too.
So I hope you guys have a great night.
I hope you guys sleep well for tomorrow, for Christmas.
And as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked,
get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Have you set for me?
deserve it.
So before I go, I guess I'll post up the Christmas schedule
one more time for those who didn't see it.
But this is the Christmas schedule.
Oh, Dad knows when I end.
He knows my fucking ending.
My ending phrases.
My outro stuff.
So Christmas party start at 3 p.m.
PST.
Roblox or Dragons.
And then you guys might, if you guys don't want to watch me
play a difficult game about climbing, we can pick something
else.
And then Chris karaoke.
And then Fortnite and random Minecraft server hopping.
And then and finally we end with another good night dragon
hey guys i'll see you guys later everyone bye guys